good morning believe nation today's  message is take risks over you embark on  pride people who sleep don't take risks  and I myself there are few people on  those who has made so many mistakes as I  have done but it's a question of have  the possibility to correct to correct  the mistake you have made that is always  allowed to you to make false and we do  do money every day thank you guys so  much for watching my question of the day  is what's the biggest risk you've ever  taken  nothing nothing what marry me save me my  biggest what's the biggest risk you've  ever taken leave it in the comments  below and we're gonna join in the  discussion thank you guys so much for  watching you need to believe and I'll  see you again tomorrow morning for  another you the shop